- Welcome back!
(audience applauding)
Taika Waititi is here.
John O'Hurley is still hanging with us.
Taika's new movie is
called, "Next Goal Wins."
So in honor of that, it's time for a game
we hilariously called "Next Roll Wins."
(audience applauding)
♪ Next roll wins ♪
But we always cap it off
with a fantastic singer.
So thank you, Jesse.
(audience laughing)
John has kindly agreed to host.
John, I now give you control of the show.
- Absolutely.
Thank you, Kelly.
- You're welcome.
- What a wonderful title.
- We are clever.
- Such a clever group of
writers, wouldn't you say?
- Yes, you're welcome, America.
- In this game, the answers
are all actors or actresses
who have won Oscars.
But the clues will be about the roles
that they had just before
they won those awards.
- Okay.
- If you know the answer,
you hit your button and you say it.
If you're wrong, the other person
will get an opportunity to steal.
- Okay.
- Okay?
- I just everyone to know, I
don't know things like this.
- I don't either.
I'm stressed out.
- I don't watch other people's work.
(all laughing)
- I only like my own.
- I watch my own stuff.
And that's great, and
that's why I made it.
To entertain myself.
- Oh my God, I love it.
- On Sunday, I just watch my box set...
(all laughing)
with the commentary on.
- I can't wait to beat you.
- And that makes me happy.
- Now I feel better.
- I'm also fiercely, fiercely competitive.
And I hate losing.
- Okay.
- If I lose, I'm gonna
trash this whole set.
- If we don't start the game,
you're not gonna get a chance.
- Very rock and roll.
- I'm trashing this place.
- Okay, sorry.
We're running outta time!
- Okay.
- Let's go.
- No, we got it.
- Now that we've had the
pre-emptory notices, here we go.
First question.
- Disclaimer, disclaimer.
- Before her third Oscar win,
she was seen alongside Steve
Martin in, "It's Complicated."
- Oh, Meryl Streep!
(buzzer dings)
- Mum, mum, mum, mum.
(bell dings)
- That's my favorite!
(audience cheering and applauding)
That's my favorite.
- How did you know that?
- I'm sorry, we needed that
in the form of a question.
- What?
- No, I'm kidding.
- Oh, I was like, "Wait, what"?
- I'm kidding, you got it.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- Question is yours.
All right, are you ready?
Good luck.
- Meryl Streep, okay.
- All right, here we go.
Question number two.
He played a high school football coach in,
"Remember the Titans" before...
- Denzel Washington!
(buzzer dings)
(bells dings)
(audience cheers)
What is happening?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
- Getting embarrassed?
(audience laughing)
- I love Denzel.
- All right, here we go.
Continuing on.
- Okay.
- Question number three.
She played a safe cracker
and daughter of Donald
Sutherland in, "The Italian Job"
before winning the...
(buzzer dings)
- Charlize Theron?
- best actress for "Monster."
- Charlize Theron, yes.
(bell dings)
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Theron, I said it wrong.
(audience applauding)
You know what?
I apologize 'cause I feel like
I said her name wrong too.
Sorry.
- That's three for Kelly.
- I'm kind of kicking your ass, Taika.
Yeah.
- Still have a chance.
- All right, here we go.
- Yeah.
You weren't kidding
about being bad at this.
(all laughing)
- I really wasn't.
I'm an honest person.
- All right, here we go.
- Ugh.
- She was a "Runaway
Bride" just before she...
(Taika stuttering)
- Oh, my gosh.
Julia Roberts.
(bell dings)
I am incredible.
- Before she was "Erin Brockovich,"
the answer is Julia Roberts.
You get it.
(audience applauding)
- You'd think I'd take it easy on you
and be a good host, but I won't.
- Number five, we're getting down...
She's almost boxing you out here.
Hold on a second.
- Oh my God, I feel powerful.
- Question number five.
- Okay.
- Before winning the Oscar
for his role in "Forrest
Gump," he won for his...
(buzzer dings)
- Well, we all know his...
- Tom Hanks!
- His role in "Philadelphia."
- Tom Hanks.
(bell dings)
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Is that game over?
Let's just end the game.
You know, gimme one.
- This man got on stage looking
all right, all right, all right in...
(buzzer dings)
- Oh for God's sake.
- Matthew McConaughey!
(bell dings)
- All right, let me read...
- All right, all right.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Before being less than all right
in "Dallas Buyers Club"
Matthew McConaughey.
Six to nothing.
- Sure be cool if you did.
- Here's the thing, all right?
- We started out friends.
- Is that we both knew the answer...
(audience laughing)
- But I'm quicker.
But I'm quicker like a cat.
- There was a mutual respect
at the beginning.
There's just none left.
- She's got a ranch...
She's got a ranch in Montana,
that's what she does.
- I'm going for it, I'm going for it.
- All right, number seven.
(siren blares)
Oh!
That is time for our last question.
Boy, you were trending too.
(all laughing)
- It's not about the amount of answers,
it's about the quality of the answers.
- It's quantity (laughing)...
Not quantity.
- Here is our final question.
We heard the buzzer there.
- How much is this one worth?
- 1,000!
- We should probably...
- This is for champion of the universe.
- We probably should say
this is worth seven points.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
So you have a...
- We should say that.
- And riding along with this,
the winning prize is the passenger seat
to a '91 Toyota Celica.
- Okay.
I like it, I like it.
- So try as hard as you can.
All right, here we go.
Last question.
- Okay.
- This actor had some "Desperate Hours"
before eating a liver with some fave beans
and a nice Chianti.
(buzzer dings)
You were in there first.
- Anthony Hopkins.
- Damn it!
(bell dings)
(audience cheering)
(siren blaring)
- All right, fine.
Thank you for hosting, John.
Everybody watch "The National Dog Show"
Thanksgiving Day on NBC.
And be sure to check out
Taika's film, "Next Goal Wins."
It's in theaters right now.
We will be right back.